[Music]
hello everyone
this year marks the 35th anniversary of
the original release of the super mario
brothers game
and today we will be announcing upcoming
super mario games and products that will
be released by
spring 2021 okay here we go
here's a classic way to play super mario
brothers
the original super mario brothers which
made its debut on nes
in 1985 can now be played on this
special game and watch system
a plus control pad is included so you
can play the game smoothly
since it's a game and watch product it
also functions as a clock
and in honor of the game's 35th
anniversary it comes with 35
little touches to discover in addition
you can play the super mario brothers
the lost levels game on it
as well as an updated version of the
title game watch ball
starring mario
game watch super mario brothers will
launch november 13th
the original nintendo handheld gaming
system is back in full color liquid
crystal display
[Music]
multiplayer mayhem pounces onto the
nintendo switch system
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
clash in this competitive super mario
brothers game
welcome to super mario brothers
with 35 players
compete against other players near and
far in this online battle game
[Music]
enemies you defeat will be sent to other
players courses
but this also works the other way around
[Music]
use the item roulette and these four
strategies
to try to outpace your opponents
keep going until you're the last mario
standing
or running this game will be an
exclusive offer for nintendo switch
online members super mario brothers 35
launches october 1st as a digital only
title
and will be available for a limited time
until march 31st
2021
[Music]
what could this one be
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there are even more ways to enjoy 35
years of super mario brothers
from now through march 2021 you can
enjoy the 35th anniversary of super
mario brothers in these ways
complete super mario related missions
and you could receive
cool rewards including a special pin set
pins are available while supplies last
so get started today and learn more by
visiting the official website
mario kart tour will be having a super
mario kart
tour event with special appearances by
mario
and donkey kong jr from the original
super mario kart game
historical super mario items and 35th
anniversary themed merchandise
will be available for purchase at the
nintendo new york store
and store.nintendo.com a 35th
anniversary themed ninja speed runs
course
is coming to the super mario maker 2
game the super smash brothers ultimate
game will be having an
in-game online tournament using super
mario series fighters
stages and items a super mario themed
splatfest is coming to the splatoon 2
game in january
keychains will also be available as a my
nintendo reward
closer to the splatfest in addition
physical splatfest t-shirts will soon be
available for
purchase online super mario themed
furniture will be added to the animal
crossing new horizons game
and there's more where that came from be
on the lookout for the following super
mario themed products
more details will be available on our
35th anniversary website
and our official nintendo of america
twitter account
plus experience four classic mario games
in super mario all-stars
this collection contains super mario
brothers super mario brothers 2
super mario brothers 3 and super mario
brothers
the lost levels the audio and visuals
are upgraded from the original
nes and famicom versions super mario
all-stars will be available in the super
nintendo entertainment system
nintendo switch online collection later
today
how is everything so far the next one
will be our last announcement
[Music]
it's me mario
run run run
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
three super mario 3d platforming
adventures
now in one collection the super mario 3d
all-stars game is coming to the nintendo
switch system
in addition to having higher resolutions
than their original versions
the games have been optimized for a
smooth gameplay experience on nintendo
switch
plus music from all three titles will be
included in the collection
in music player mode you can enjoy your
favorite mario tunes anytime
anywhere super mario 3d all-stars will
launch on september 18th a limited run
retail edition
and a digital edition of the game will
be available for a limited time
until the end of march 2021 pre-orders
will be available starting today
on nintendo eshop
what did you think of our super mario
brothers 35th anniversary direct
as you can see from the original super
mario brothers game
to the latest installment a variety of
super mario games can be played on
nintendo switch
in addition if you include all related
games there are even more available
we hope you'll take this opportunity to
play each and every one of them
that's it for our super mario brothers
35th anniversary direct
we'd like to close with a look back at
the history of super mario brothers
thank you for watching and playing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do
[Music]
three
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
go
[Music]
foreign wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
don't be scared
get ready
you